[Music]
hi everyone thanks for coming I think
I'll go ahead and get started my name is
Ryan Smith I work for Wu trick as a data
scientist and I'm here to talk to you
today about transfer learning in natural
language processing and how small teams
with small datasets can utilize it to
still build powerful model so yeah
transfer running in natural language
processing so what we'll be covering in
this talk is first we're going to look
at a real problem that we at what Rick
are solving using NLP and deep learning
and we'll go through a brief discussion
of the methods we tried on our way to
using deep learning to solve this
problem next we'll go into how transfer
learning can help small teams with less
data still compete with bigger
corporations with established teams of
data scientists and along the way we'll
be looking at the results we achieve
from applying these methods so what Rick
who are we and what do we do whoo trick
is a modern feedback management platform
we help companies measure and boost
customer happiness to accomplish this we
do three main things so first collection
we track customer experience metrics by
gathering feedback next is analysis we
provide insights into what customers are
talking about by classifying feedback at
scale and then finally action we help
companies align around critical business
problems identified through feedback and
take action to drive growth and protect
revenue now the focus today will be on
analysis as where you could imagine most
of the machine learning will take place
so the problem that we want to solve is
that our surveys collect a lot of
feedback and we wanted to be able to
deliver insights to our customers in an
automated fashion so two main questions
that we are concerned with our first
what set of topics is the customer
commenting on so this is a multi-label
classification problem and next how does
a customer feel about the product or
service and this is your classic
sentiment analysis problem so here's an
example of the dashboard we
used to present these insights just so
that you're familiar with our the
problem that we're trying to solve and
the insights that were surfacing so if
you look at the top row you can see a
piece of text this is a response to an
NPS question a Net Promoter Score
question and the customer said enjoyed
my first order if nothing goes wrong in
shipping happy to recommend so what we
want to be able to do is to tell our
users that this comment was about
shipping and packaging the customer had
a positive sentiment overall the
sentiment related to shipping and
packaging was neutral and then on the
left hand side you'll be able to see the
breakdowns of various tags which is what
we call our labels that are being
applied to each feedback and how those
breakdowns compare to each other so
naturally the more accurate our
prediction systems are the less margin
of error we're going to have around
these breakdowns that were showing to
customers and so in order to evaluate
our models we have to have a set of
metrics that we want to benchmark them
against so this is precision recall and
f1 score many of you may be familiar
with them already I'll just give a brief
overview for in case anyone is
unfamiliar or hasn't touched them in a
while so precision is in classification
given that we've tagged a piece of
feedback in our case or overall just
tagged a piece of data how often are we
correct so this is a measure of every
tag how certain are we that that should
be applied by our model recall is what
percent of feedback that we should have
tagged we actually ended up tagging so
this is more of a coverage metric that
tells how much of the feedback we ended
up covering and then f1 score is just an
easy way to combine these two metrics
into one number and so the equation for
it is right there two times precision
times recall over precision plus recall
and we'll be reporting f1 score when we
report our results for our models now
our formal problem that we use machine
learning to
solve is given the piece of feedback and
it's industry what tags should be
applied we'll get into will discuss this
problem in general because it's a little
bit easier to focus on and then at the
end we'll round it out how we also
incorporate sentiment analysis so this
as I said before is a multi-label
classification problem so to each
feedback we're going to apply a set of
binary labels which means that we're
going to have a vector for every single
possible tag that we could apply of
zeros and ones
so each feedback could have zero one or
more feedback or or more tags associated
with it now our metrics that we use are
like I said precision recall and f1
score but for each tag since for a
classification problem multi class
you're able to combine these metrics
together but for multi-label it's a
little bit easier to see them separated
apart so now that we're applying machine
learning to this problem we have to
decide how to go forward so for business
purposes usually cost efficient and time
efficient solutions are a little bit
easier to implement and nice to start
with so I'm going to take you through
our first approaches which were using
basic models and utilizing an existing
service so for basic models in NLP the
most basic model is bag of words and
it's very common because it shows good
success and it's very easy to implement
so for those of you that don't know bag
of words is where you treat document as
a one hot encoded set of vectors where
each vector represents one word that's
there and so you have a set of sparse
vectors that is just representing all
your words and you can combine these by
usually adding them or just anding them
together so that you have a one present
if the word is there and zeros if it's
not then you feed your resulting vector
for that document into any kind of
classifier that you want to so logistic
regression model SVM or a simple neural
network and then that gives you your
classification rule based methods are
what linguists usually come up with or
people with knowledge of the domain that
you are predicting in and so rule
methods can range from very specific to
very general rule based methods are good
because they are able to come up with
very specific targeted solutions that
meet your problem but they also are
time-consuming to make for each specific
problem that you're trying to solve and
the more general they are the more prone
to error they usually are good things
about basic models is that first they
give a good baseline so that you know
how much how much effort should be put
into improving your solutions if you're
trying a more complicated solution and
not achieving that much better results
or worse results than your baseline then
you know to shut it off from there and
it's not a good use of your time
also basic models you can keep iterating
particularly bag-of-words since you're
just feeding a feature set into a
classifier there's still a lot of things
to tuned for that classifier for
instance we were able to tune around our
bag of words model logistic regression
using class weights due to class and
balance problem and then finally basic
models require that you have a
production system in place which is
always great to start with even if you
just have dummy data but even having
these basic classifiers we'll be able to
show you if incorrect classifications or
classifications you may not have been
expecting will break your models or
break anything about your pipeline so
here are the results we got from our
first basic models so on the left is the
bag of words model on the right is bag
of words combined with a very general
rule based method and the graph is
showing an average f1 across all tags in
our test dataset for applying these
methods so problems basically our
numbers are actually let me say what a
good baseline would be a good place to
find where you want to achieve accuracy
so basically we want to show what f1
score is good enough for us and the
higher our f1 score the
lower margin of error is going to be
shown when we're showing aggregate
metrics to customers and so we see these
basic models and we think we can improve
upon them and some of the reasons that
our basic models don't do as well is
language is hard to model you're here
for an NLP talk I'm sure you have
encountered problems before where people
say certain things that do not translate
well to basic models so for example the
engineering costs to implement your
product was too high people are talking
more about manpower and less about
actual pricing of your service and so
bag-of-words method would mistakenly tag
this as price when in fact it should be
about something else
and this leads us to bag-of-words and
rule base rule-based methods can
certainly be improved upon
so the other very easy system to set up
is use an existing service that predicts
what you are trying to predict so we
started with this we used Google
prediction API which was around about 2
years ago when we started looking into
this problem had a very easy interface
you would send in a CSV with a piece of
feedback labeled and it would tell using
a giant training set it would just give
you a model that you can then query to
find your predictions
it had binary or multi class options for
us we were we used a set of binary
classifiers which ended up being a
little more expensive than we had hoped
because it was a set of a bunch of
different models for every single piece
of feedback but it did give give better
results than our basic models so a it
passed the baseline which is great and B
it was giving solid results problem with
it was that eventually Google deprecated
it and a couple months before that it
started failing regression tests we
looked into it thought huh why is this
acting so weird and then a month later
oh hey we're not going to continue the
service so this is one of the problems
with blackbox models is if things go
wrong you have no control over it
Google eventually came out with Auto ml
but this was I think a year and a half
later and we needed something now
to improve upon our basic models so we
thought about deep learning so deep
learning is fun as we all know but it's
relatively time-consuming and you want
to make sure it's worth it before you
invest the time and effort to implement
it into your pipeline so that being said
there are for example great packages
today like Kerris or pi torch where you
can very easily implement basic deep
learning models but usually they require
a lot of data so we used a basic
convolutional neural network and L STM
which is a recurrent neural network
models on our limited training set the
CNN did very well or did better than our
baseline the LS TM was not effective and
here are the results from that so you
can see we showed a little bit
improvement including the CNN into our
set of models the reason the LS TM did
so poorly in the CNN didn't give us a
huge result result increase over our
existing models is that we have small
training sets so part of our problem is
that we have many different industries
that we are focused on providing tags
for and to be able to quickly add
industries we need to be able to
manually label this data quickly so
usually we hover around a thousand to
2,000 rows of feedback being labeled for
our problem now manual labeling is
time-consuming and it requires domain
knowledge about the topic you're
labeling about so general things about
price or if somebody's asking for a
feature are usually pretty easy to label
but if it's a little bit more
specialized for example some of our
customers are in the financial sector
you usually need a little bit of domain
knowledge to tell if people are talking
about various trading terminology and
other things there so we also have a
class imbalance problem a lot of these
tags that we apply only show up in five
to ten percent of the feedback this
becomes a problem when every incremental
thousand rows of feedback you add only
has 50 rows of the tag that you're
trying to apply and so only 50 examples
of the classifier to learn from so this
leads us to how can we learn from so few
example
and still compete with companies that
have hundreds of thousands of feedback
to train their models and the employees
to tag them enter transfer learning so
transfer learning the whole point of it
is to make as much use of as much data
as possible and so basically if we have
models trained on data that seems
uncorrelated to our problem we still
want to be able to take advantage of
them to train our specific classifier so
this is the general pipeline for
transfer learning we start with a
general data model that learns from
usually a much larger set of general
data and then gives us some unrelated
output and then we have a task specific
model that is trained on a much smaller
set of tagged data and then gives us our
task specific output so usually that
unrelated output is not helpful to us we
want to find a way to then bring it over
to where the general model feeds into
our task specific model and can
influence it to improve our task
specific output so more data is better
and how do we utilize it some common
techniques right now to make the general
model feed into the task specific model
include using parts of imagenet models
which was a huge improvement in computer
vision in 2016
using prior to sprits distributions for
Bayesian analysis which is where you
from your own knowledge of the domain
can superimpose a distribution on to the
problem that you're trying to solve and
then in NLP we have word vectors and
then within the last year language
models being used as transfer learning
methodologies so we'll start with
transfer running and computer vision
image net I was a huge advancement in
the field of computer vision and so what
image net is is it's a very large
database of labeled images where there's
many different labels and many different
subsections of images that you can look
into and one of the things that people
found when training models over across
this huge image net database was that
convolutional neural networks tended to
learn lower level features in the lower
layers and then higher love or sorry
higher level features such as edges
shapes and colors in the beginning
layers of the model and then the later
layers would be more tuned towards that
models problem that it was trying to
solve so this is kind of like saying
that I have a huge database of images
that are all labeled for cats and dogs
but then I want to be able to apply that
knowledge to still labeling things like
tables and chairs what will happen is
that the model trained on a huge
database of images will learn these
things such as edges shapes and colors
and then be able to transfer that
knowledge to also applying it to the
tables and chairs data set so here's a
very dumbed-down example of a transfer
learning being applied in computer
vision so say we have a very large
database of fruit classification and so
we have this fruit classifier that
learns what apples and various other
fruits look like the beginning layers of
the model will learn about edges shapes
colors and then progressively get more
fine-grained until it arrives at a fruit
classifier that can tell apples from
oranges and pears what we want to do is
to train a vegetable classifier however
our vegetable dataset is much smaller
what we can do instead is take that same
base model that knows about edges shapes
colors so the first two layers there and
then cut off the part that is actually a
fruit classifier and put on an empty
uninitialized classifier at the end and
what we can then do is train our new
model on a much smaller data set so this
helps because what's happening is we're
reducing the feature space of the
vegetable classifier from a totally
pixelated RGB values image into instead
some vector that represents edges shapes
and colors and so this lets us learn a
lot more quickly about what types of
things will lead to being a vegetable or
one type of vegetable over the other
obviously this is a very simple example
and no
totally representative of what happens a
lot of the time it's not very obvious
what layers of your model are actually
pertaining exactly to your problem in
which ones are super high levels so
that's a huge area of focus of trying to
investigate that and figure that out so
that is mmm transfer learning in
computer vision now transfer learning in
natural language processing so the first
thing that came out was 2012 people
found word vectors there's a very big
paper published by Google I believe that
was a huge stride and really helped
knack natural language processing models
improve and so what word vectors are are
basically encoding a word instead of in
the bag of words format of a one hot
encoding into a smaller n dimensional
vector which can then be applied to a
machine learning model in the same way
as bag of words or into a long
short-term memory model or other
recurrent Nets to learn things about
your data set so weird vectors learn one
initial layer of a model which is the
embedding layer usually and they usually
only capture one aspect of language so
for example your words for word vectors
are always going to have the same
vectors no matter of the context that
they appear in and then good advantages
about word vectors are that you do not
need label data to train them they
trained over any class they trained over
any corpus of text so all you need is
the text and a few parameters to set
when training them and then they also
led to things like the infamous Google
News Google News generated word vectors
which was a public data set of I believe
three points something million word
vectors for people to use that have been
trained over a large corpus of Google
News articles so word vectors were great
but we wanted to improve on them and so
in the last year language models became
a source for transfer learning in
natural language processing so what a
language model is a
is a way to predict what words will be
mentioned next in a piece of text we'll
go over that later but the main parts
about language models are that they
learn multiple general purpose layers so
a language model can be an entire model
as opposed to just an embedding layer
offered by word vectors so a language
model is trained to model language and
not just words so in this example we
have the two mm two pieces of feedback I
hit the ball and our website got a lot
of hits for word vectors these will both
be modeled the word hit we'll both be
modeled by the same vector but for a
language model because it has multiple
layers we're able to differentiate what
vectors will show up from the results of
this language model based on the context
around those words and also like word
vectors another great thing is that you
do not need any labeled training data
when training a language model so here's
the what is a language model brief or
simple demonstration so basically a
language model seeks to predict the next
word in a sequence at each point of the
sequence so in our example right here we
have the classic NLP sentence of the
quick brown fox jumped over whatever and
what we want to do is at each word in
the process predict what word will come
next so we start with a beginning of
sentence label and then we send it into
a recurrent layer which then feeds into
a softmax layer which then gives us a
distribution of what are predicted next
word is we train the first part of the
sequence expecting the word the then in
the next input we input the and train it
to expect quick then we input quick and
train it to expect brown and so on so
one of the great things about language
models like I mentioned is that you do
not need labeled training data to train
them this is because all you have to do
is feed in an existing corpus of text
like a giant database of Wikipedia
articles or the penn treebank and you
can quickly be able to model or and
predict what words will come next in
that text
so one of the so language models are
usually thought of as
encoder/decoder architectures there's
other ways to go about this but this is
kind of the most basic way to do it
especially from a deep learning
perspective and so the encoder part is
usually all the recurrent layers that
you feed in from the beginning so after
the embedding which will usually occur
in the input part you would have the
recurrent layers acting as the encoder
which then feed to softmax layer or
layers which act as a decoder and then
they will give you your distribution
over possible words on the output so the
soft there's many different ways to go
about this one of the cool advancements
last year was freezing the decoder layer
to be the same as you're embedding
layers so that the encoder was really
doing all the work
and so what we can do using these
encoders and decoders is kind of a
similar thing to what we did in the
fruits and vegetables example so you
have a general corpus that you're
inputting into your language model so
this general corpus could be anything
like a giant Wikipedia data set the pen
treebank a Twitter stream whatever and
basically all it's learning to do is
model that language and predict the next
word at each sequence of the input so
you have the encoder and the decoder
present in that model then what we can
do is we can dieta we can dis remove the
Rakow der and put on our own
uninitialized classifier that we then
train on our much smaller data set so
the great benefit of this is that the
encoder already has a lot of the
intricacies of how language is used and
then we can learn from a much smaller
feature set for our task specific
classification so overall the main thing
from language models and using them and
transfer learning is that you want to
initialize your model state with the
encoder of a general task language model
and so you can iterate this process if
necessary what that means is that we can
start with a giant overall model of how
human language works so the language
that you're modeling specifically say
English you
start with just a giant trove of
Wikipedia articles on written in English
and then you can take a set of unlabeled
just straight text from your own domain
that you're trying to solve so for us
that would be customer feedback and
train that language model more on your
domain of text then what you do after
that is the same process as before you
put on a classifier at the end but so
basically you can keep making your
language model as specific as you want
on decreasing sizes but more increasing
specificity of corpuses of text so this
has been commonly referred to as NLP s
image net moment in a great paper by
Sebastian Reuter that came out a few
months ago and the headline of that is
that finally starting in 2018 we can use
transfer learning to quickly product
size deep learning models for NLP and
the reason we can do this is that we can
quickly make use of publicly available
text here are some examples like wiki
text the penn treebank twitter stream or
even as a recent open a paper proved a
random web crawl across the internet
modeling how humans use language and
even some models are available I believe
Salesforce has an AWD LS TM that they
trained over the wiki text 103 data set
and you can just download that and
remove the decoder part and start your
classifications from there so our
transfer learning model was also modeled
over wiki text 103 like I said there's
pre-existing versions of these we
trained our own and then what we did
after that was refined that language
model across a domain or a corpus of our
customer feedback in order to tailor it
to our domain and then we at the end
took off the decoder and put on our own
classifier and trained it for each of
our industries over that smaller task
specific training set and here are the
results from that so we showed a 17%
improvement over our basic methods which
felt very gratifying and we kept kind of
a linear growth which is I haven't
really seen
for in machine learning from all the
different tasks the different methods
that we tried on the weight of this we
usually saw a little bit of logarithmic
growth but so this was a great
improvement and it really made us feel
validated that we pursued the transfer
learning approach but we did want a
comparison still so Auto ml came out
about six months after we implemented
this into our production pipeline and we
wanted to see ok well Google probably
has it figured out pretty well let's see
how we compare to what they've done so
we trained Auto ml on our own data set
and we actually achieved 8 percent
improvement over their f1 average f1
score on our test set which felt very
validating and further we then used our
transfer learning approach on our
sentiment model if you remember from
before I said we wanted to see how
customers feel about the product or
service they're being offered and each
aspect of that service so we use our
sentiment model when determining aspect
based sentiment analysis for our tags
and our sentiment model was actually
trained on our much smaller data set of
customer feedback reviews in order to
get our positive or negative scores and
we actually achieved 96.5% accuracy
across our test set a court in
comparison to 92% accuracy for Google
which also felt great and goes to show
that user using transfer learning
especially just because Google is Google
doesn't mean you can't beat them in your
own domain so those were kind of the
those were the main improvements that we
made over our models and the main
benchmarks that we reached so just to
summarize some of the stages of the talk
steps to take when you're implementing
deep learning or solving a machine
learning based problem first evaluate if
you do need deep learning and transfer
learning because it's always good to
pursue other methods that may be simpler
and easier to implement and then if you
do find that you need to use deep
learning transfer learning is a great
place to start in NLP because we often
have access to general unspecific data
that we can then
trained a language model on and refined
to our specific problem domain and then
finally language models are a great
improvement but NLP is still not near
computer vision in terms of accuracy and
so there's still room for improvement
over language models in the transfer
learning space and because of this you
want to make use of as many building
blocks that can transfer an abstract
your data prediction out across those as
possible and maybe you'll find the next
big moment for NLP and yeah here are
some references so the paper I mentioned
before and lp's imagenet moment has
arrived by Sebastian Reuter and the
paper that actually turned us on to this
method of transfer learning a couple
years ago or a year ago when we
implemented it was universal language
model fine tuning for text
classification both of them are great
reads and I would very much recommend
reading those and yeah that is about it
thank you for coming and if you have any
questions feel free to ask them a great
presentation thank you I was just
wondering is there a lower bound to the
data set size where this stays effective
for the general unspecific corpus or for
the task specific for the task specific
data so there's always going to be a
lower bound and it's going to depend
greatly on your data so for us like I
mentioned we have a class imbalance
problem
which means that sometimes we only have
tags show up in five to ten percent of
the data because of this our lower bound
we found was much lower than they
mentioned in the paper so the universal
language model fine tuning paper used a
balanced sentiment dataset to conduct
their research and they found that they
were able to achieve similar results to
an LS TM overall two hundred thousand
parts of that data set with only two
hundred rows of the sentiment labeled
sentiment data and so the lower bound is
obviously going to depend but what with
transfer learning and findings from that
paper we found that it's much lower than
using classic deep learning methods
I'll ask a question you mentioned the f1
score improved would you say that your
customers noticed was there a product
implication of that this was actually um
we did not have this exposed yet so we
actually just released this service we
call it our CX I CX insight service we
just released that recently and we
actually only had one customer before we
implemented the transfer learning
approach they to be honest weren't
totally paying attention that much to
their changing things but what we found
was that we were able to provide a much
smaller margin of error with this change
in accuracy which was great that's a
whole nother talk that I could get into
about determining margin of errors from
classifiers but the improvement in f1
score specifically how it was an 8%
improvement over Google really allows us
to offer a smaller margin of error than
if we had used them which was very
rewarding
[Music]